Welcome back to recitation.
In this video what
I'd like you to do
is work on proving
the following product
rule for the del operator.
So we're going to let
capital F be a vector field
and u be a scalar function.
And we want to show the
product rule for the del
operator which--
it's in quotes but it
should remind you of the product
rule we have for functions.
And it is that del dot
the quantity u times
F-- so u is the scalar function
and F is the vector field-- is
actually equal to the gradient
of u dotted with F plus u
times del dot F. Where F
again is the vector field.
So why don't you take a
moment to prove this fact
and you can pause the
video while doing that.
And then when you're ready
to check if your solution is
correct, bring the video back
up and I'll show you what I did.
OK, welcome back.
Again what we wanted
to do is prove
this sort of pseudo product
rule for the del operator.
And what we're doing
is we're trying
to see what happens if
you have a vector field
and you multiply it
by a scalar function
and you apply the
del operator to that.
So we're going to see
if we actually come up
with what we should on the
right-hand side, which,
since I'm calling it a
rule, we really hope we do.
In fact, we will.
So let me start off.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to write symbolically
what the left-hand side means.
And then we're going to
break it up into pieces
and show you get, in
fact, what you would
get on the right-hand side.
So symbolically,
what do we have?
Oh actually, first
I'm going to call F--
the components of F,
as is usually done
in lecture--
capitals P, Q, and R.
So those will be
the components of F.
That's how we've been
denoting this, usually.
And notice that if we wanted
F to be a vector field in two
dimensions, we'd just
make R 0, and then we'd
have a vector field
in two dimensions.
So we can certainly
do that if we want,
but we're going to prove
it in a little more--
in the three-dimensional case.
So remember that del dotted with
any vector field is supposed
to be-- symbolically, what was
written was you should think
about this as del, del x, comma
del, del y, comma del, del z,
dotted with this
vector field, u*F.
Now what is this vector field?
Because u is a scalar, when I
multiply u by the vector field
F, the components are going to
be u capital P comma u capital
Q comma u capital R. So
those are my components.
Now symbolically,
this is what we've
seen when we're looking at the
del operator acting on a vector
field.
So what do we actually do?
Well, what we actually
do, of course,
is we take the x derivative
of the first component,
we take the y derivative
of the second component,
and we take the z derivative
of the third component.
And then we add those together.
So it's really a symbolic
idea of a dot product.
It's not a true
dot product here.
But let's actually write
down what we get there.
We get del del x of
the quantity u*P,
plus del del y of the
quantity u*Q plus del del z
of the quantity u*R. That's
exactly what this symbolically
means is this, what I've
written in the next line down.
So maybe I should
write equals again.
This is another equals.
The top thing equals
the next line down,
equals the next line down.
And just to have it nice and
even I'll put the equals there,
so when we look back
it's easy to see.
Now how do I deal with this?
Well, notice that u is a
function and P is a function.
Why is that?
Because P was a component
of a vector field.
So it is just a function that
is in the first component
of the vector field.
P, Q, and R are all
individually functions
that depend on x, y, and z.
So here, at this
step, I can actually
take the regular product
rule we have for functions.
And I can do it in this
one, this one, and this one.
And what I'm going to do, so I
don't have to write del del x
and del del y all
over the place,
I'm going to use the subscripts
notation for derivatives.
So I'm going to write,
what this actually
equals is u sub x
times P plus u P sub x.
So here, the del del x is now
corresponding to a subscript.
So notice that I've just used
the product rule on functions
at this step, because u is a
function and P is a function.
I can do the same thing for
the y derivative of u*Q.
I get u sub y Q plus u Q sub y.
And then the last component,
I do the same thing for z.
I get u sub z R plus u R sub z.
Now if I made a mistake it
will become very apparent
in the next moment.
But I don't think
I made a mistake.
I want to remind us
where we want to go,
and then we'll see if we
have the pieces to get there.
So I'm going to go back over
to the side we have over here.
And I want to remind
you, we started off
with a del operator acting on
this vector field u times F,
capital F. And what
we'd like to see
is if we can get this to
equal the gradient of u
dotted with the vector
field plus u times
the del operator acting on F.
So let's see if
we can first find
components of the vector
field and components
of the gradient of u.
And let's see where those are.
They're actually very
nicely placed here.
Notice that this
underlined component
is the first component
of gradient u
and the first component of F.
And this underlined component
is the second component
of gradient of u
and the second component of
F. And this third underlined
component here is the
third component of grad u
and the third component of F.
So if I take those three
components together--
I'm going to write
the equals up here--
I get exactly grad
u dotted with F.
That's the first thing I get.
And then I'm going to
see what else I get.
But let me just make sure you
understand, look at these three
underlined components together.
You get u sub x times P plus
u sub y times Q plus u sub z
times R. Well, [u x, u y, u z]
is the gradient vector field
for u, and [P, Q, R] is
F. So when I dot those,
I get exactly u_x*P
plus u_y*Q plus u_z*R.
You notice these two, or
the dot product of this,
gives you those
three components.
And now there are three
components remaining.
Notice what they
all have in common.
They all have a u
in the first spot.
And then it's
multiplied by P sub x,
and then here it's
multiplied by Q sub y,
and here it's
multiplied by R sub z.
But that is exactly-- P sub
x plus Q sub y plus R sub
z is exactly the del operator
acting on this vector field F.
So this is something
you've seen previously.
So I'm going to do
these as squiggles.
That's exactly equal to u times
the del operator of this vector
field F.
So again let me remind
you, del dot F actually
is going to give you P sub
x plus Q sub y plus R sub z.
And then if I multiply that
by a u, I get this u in front.
So what I have done is
for an arbitrary function
u-- I guess I've assumed
that function had
first derivatives so that
I could do all this stuff--
and for a vector field
that had first derivatives,
I showed that if I take
the del operator of u times
the vector field, I actually
get the gradient of u
dotted with the vector
field plus u times
the del operator of
the vector field.
So that is what
I wanted to show.
If you remember,
what I wanted to show
was exactly that sort of pseudo
product rule for this del
operator.
So I think that that
is where I'll stop.
I'm going to step
off to the side,
so you can see it all
again, for a moment.
But that's it.
So that's where I'll stop.